- [Narrator] This chip controls your car,
stores data about what you
bought and runs the software
on your laptop.
These chips have come to power
our lives, and only a handful
of fabrication plants or fabs
in the world have the know-how
and infrastructure to make them.
So most of the chips are
produced outside of the US
like at this fab in Singapore
- The bill of fab is a big investment.
- [Narrator] And now the
world is running out of chips
because companies can't
make them fast enough.
- When order really flooding in.
We had to turn on every single piece
of machine that we can
find in the factory.
- [Narrator] The pandemic
rattled supply chains
and led to a surge in
demand for electronics
when people were stuck at home.
While a perfect storm
of natural disasters,
a fire at one of the world's
leading auto chip makers
and the ongoing US-China trade
war disrupted the production
and distribution of semiconductors.
This shortage has affected
whether you can drive a Jeep
off the lot or buy a new PlayStation 5.
We visit one of the world's
largest contract chip makers
to see the complex process
and why there's no quick
fix to the supply crunch.
- Chip usually it takes about
two to three months to make.
- [Narrator] Daniel Rajkumar
is a manufacturing manager
at one of the fabs at Global Foundries.
The American company is
the third largest contract
chip manufacturer in the world.
Companies like Intel, AMD and Bosch
give some of their circuitry
designs to Global Foundries.
And then it's fabs like
this one in Singapore
manufacture the chips.
- Once we finish the
fabrication of the circuitry,
it has to go for testing.
It has to go for repackaging.
- [Narrator] Altogether it
could take as much as six months
before a chip is ready
to go into your tech.
This long process starts here,
at the center of the fab
called the clean room.
- Before going into the clean room,
we need to gown up.
- [Narrator] Because chips can
be as small as a fingernail
and crammed with billions of components,
they have to be handled with great care.
- Any form of dust that
falls onto the wafers
you will cause the chip
to be the defective.
And then now we are able
to go into the air shower.
Okay.
- [Narrator] Global Foundries
says this clean room
is a thousand times cleaner
than an operating room.
And it also takes up a lot of space.
- Two footballs field.
That's how big it is.
We have about seven to 800 machines.
- [Narrator] It's also yellow in here
because chips are sensitive to UV rays.
And this lighting has none of that.
- This is always the first step.
- [Narrator] The starter
material for any chip
is here in this room.
These super thin disks are called wafers
and made from silicon.
Eventually one of these
will produce about 1000
to 1500 individual chips.
But before it does, the wafer is placed
in a special container.
- We have the raw silicon.
We are now trying to
register this material
and translate into our wafer carrier.
- [Narrator] Each carrier
can hold up to 25 wafers
and there are about 4,000 of these
moving around the facility at one time.
- We are also the source of particles
when we go into the clean room.
- [Narrator] So never
once during manufacturing
does the wafer come in contact
with any of the workers.
- You will bring the wafers
directly to the machine.
And in this foundry, basically 95%
of all processing jobs is fully automated.
- [Narrator] These raw wafers are cleaned
before starting a process
that Rajkumar describes
as similar to making layered cake.
- The main function of diffusion cleaners
is basically to go layers of
oxide or to dap the nitrite
onto the silicon.
- [Narrator] That creates
a protective coating.
Next is a layer that makes
the wafer light-sensitive.
So it's ready for one of
the most important steps
called lithography.
- This is the most expensive
module in any wafer foundry.
The number of lithography machine
will define how many
wafers you can produce
in a month or a year.
- [Narrator] One lithography
machine can cost anywhere
between 25 million to
over 100 million dollars.
And that's because it's responsible
for adding layers of the circuitry.
Basically electronic
components like transistors
and diodes that allow the
chips eventually store data
or run apps.
- What I'm holding here is
basically a (indistinct) design
of a circuitry.
- [Narrator] Inside this
pink box is a photo mask,
which is like a glass stencil.
And clients send these
directly to Global Foundries.
The lithography machine blasts UV light
through the photo mask and prints patterns
on the wafer over and over again.
The difference between an
advanced chip for a 5G smartphone
versus one for your credit card comes down
to the type of wavelength that's used.
Shorter wavelengths mean
you can edge finer features
and get more performance out of the chips.
Some of these transmitters are so small
that they're measured in nanometers
and compared to DNA strands.
Once the circuitry pattern is imprinted,
the wafer has to be charged.
- These machines use a lot of energy
to produce electrical charge
that allows the electrical
to flow to the chip
and also creates the
different type of function
for your electrical chips.
- Rajkumar says many of
these steps are repeated
hundreds of times before
the fabrication is complete.
And to get to this point,
these orders have to be made
at least a year in advance.
- I have a demo wafers here.
- [Narrator] The finished
wafers are tested
then finally sliced into individual chips.
- One is this small die wafers,
which is mainly useful
bank cards or chips.
And then you have the other one
which is the bigger die wafers
which can go into other
kinds of applications
like computer processing chips
or electrical appliances.
- [Narrator] Global Foundry
says it's fab at Singapore
typically makes about
600,000 wafers a year.
But with the recent surge in demand,
it's making around 120,000 more.
- This whole year is fully booked out.
We don't have any more
space for new customers.
- [Narrator] Tan Yew Kong
is the vice president
and general manager of Global
Foundries Fab 7 in Singapore.
And he says, there's no quick solution.
- There's no space that you can house
another lithography
tool or any other tools
that you'd like to buy.
It is a (indistinct) easily,
a one year to 15 months
before you can see a tool that
is coming into your factory.
- [Narrator] It's not just
a backlog of equipment,
but Tan says expanding or building a fab
from the ground up would
require deep investments.
More than the $1.4 billion
that Global Foundries
has already committed to spend this year
on expanding its three
fabs around the world.
- You easily need to spend
7 billion to 15 billion
depending on the size of the
factory you want to build
and the technology that
you're gonna develop
can easily take you decades
to build the foundations.
- [Narrator] So to fill as many orders
as quickly as possible,
the company turned on idle machines
and opened this factory control tower.
Engineers here have a bird's-eye
view of the entire fab.
And the green boxes show
which machines are running
at max capacity.
Before this control tower
when there was a problem,
engineers had to sort through data
and piece together information themselves.
- Compared to today, just
looking at the screen
you already know that this
is a piece of machine.
You need to pay attention now.
- [Narrator] Tan says any
time saved is precious
but to truly address the shortage,
the company is working more
closely with its clients,
suppliers and the government.
- We're going to continue
seeing more government support
because it is becoming
such an important part
of the entire global supply chain.
- There's no reason why
Americans should wait.
We're investing aggressively
in areas like semiconductors
and batteries.
- [Narrator] The Biden administration
has proposed $50 billion
to boost America's chip production.
That's because while the
US is one of the largest
semiconductor markets, the
majority of the complex
and expensive manufacturing
happens at a few companies
based in China and East Asia.
- That's because the world's
biggest foundry in the world,
TSMC is located in Taiwan.
Samsung also has a sizeable foundry
as well as some Chinese players.
- [Narrator] This concentration
of fabs means any disruption
to the supply chain,
like a drought in Taiwan.
Or political tensions with China
can have big ripple effects.
Especially when global
demand is expected to grow
by more than 12% this year.
- We have technologies like 5G
and artificial intelligence.
And these types of advanced technology
means that more chips would be needed
to operate the devices
that we use every day
- [Narrator] To meet that demand,
the Chip Industry Association
says it will require an
investment of $3 trillion globally
over the next three decades.
So for us to buy new devices,
Tan says his fab will work
around the clock
as it turns this challenge
into a business opportunity.
- From the ambitions of
wanting to grow the company,
this is definitely a
positive point for us.
This over demand is gonna
be around for a while.